xavier fallières bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin en direct sur rt
france alors on le voyait le couvre-
fait donc débat aux pays bas pour la
justice une violation des libertés pour
le premier ministre une nécessité pour
lutter contre la propagation des
variants en tant que professionnels
soignants comment est-ce que vous jugez
la mesure du couvre-feu est ce que c'est
efficace
le problème quand on apprit la levée de
la mesure hier au bloc ça a été un peu
la stupéfaction tout le monde pour dire
ok il est très difficile de prouver
quelle action en ce moment entre la
limitation à une personne à la maison le
groupe feu qu'est ce qui marche mais est
ce qu'on a besoin d'aller faire des
études en double aveugle pour savoir ce
qui est efficace non
donc on approuve le couvre-feu à 9
heures c'est pas un problème comme
disait la dame qui fait 3 il fait sombre
et il faut absolument éviter les
rassemblements de gens c'est le plus
important et c'est ce qui va
certainement marché et justement tous
les rassemblements qu'on a vu toutes ces
protestations ces gens réunis dans la
rue ça vous inquiète
aujourd'hui c'est inquiétant c'est de
voir comment tout ça a été attisée par
des rappels de seconde guerre mondiale
et c'est alors que tôt quand on regarde
dans les autres pays européens qui nous
entoure il ya des couvre-feux quasiment
partout et personne ne se pose la
question tout le monde suit la règle ça
ça a été assez assez surprenant soit
bien dire de de voir ses réactions de
violence et c'est tant que gens restent
dehors priori en distance en 10 ans à
sciences sociales mais bon il ya
certaines règles c'est surtout d'éviter
que les gens aillent faire la fête à
l'intérieur à plusieurs et saas etc
c'est le problème majeur c'est là qu'on
justification du golfe et le port du
masque on s'en souvient avait fait aussi
débat ans dans le pays
comment est ce que vous comprenez que
les néerlandais soit autant opposé à
aux mesures prises pour endiguer la
pandémie auteur opposé je pense qu'on
laisse peut-être beaucoup trop de place
à une minorité qui est content
bon c'est vrai au début la l'om est ça
aussi dit pas le masque ça sert à rien
tout le monde a essayé de suivre jean
bien dire maintenant tout le monde met
un masque et personnes se posent la
question ça se passe très bien
le couvre-feu bas tout le monde entre 1
9 heures donc parce que c'est des fois
donné beaucoup d'importance à une
minorité comme virus par est qui et
c'est de propager des idées que
finalement peu partage alors en tout cas
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui dans
les hôpitaux du pays
est ce que les services hospitaliers
sont sous tension ces derniers jours
alors ça aussi c'est un problème quand
dans donc dans le jugement de ce juge
des référés que la pression sur les
soins ne justifie pas on a pour
l'instant une embellie quand vous avez
dit baye a varié en anglais donc une
mutation à l'intérieur ce vernis à
ongles est très inquiétante pour
l'instant mais une embellie donc on
profite d'essayer de les soirées de
rétablir les soins réguliers donc la
pression baisse avec ce week end où
beaucoup de gens ont fait du patin à
glace ou prou sous les soins et
heureusement qu'on a moins de poids ces
impôts vide
ça nous laisse l'occasion de d'obérer
tous ces patients ce sous licence qui
sont sur des listes d'attentes pour
l'instant très très longue
concert et sur emma timone pression
maximale donc aujourd'hui on est dans
les hôpitaux 1
et concernant la politique vaccinale on
en est ou aux pays bas
quelles sont les populations
prioritaires est-ce que les néerlandais
sont volontaires pour cette campagne
comment est-ce que ça se passe se passe
pour l'instant je dois bien dire très
bien donc au niveau médecin veut juste
les seulement les médecins et des
infirmières qui sont en contact
permanent dans les hôpitaux avec des
patients covit sont vaccinés ensuite bas
les gens âgés sont vaccinés les
infirmiers infirmières les soignants
dans la maison de retraite les maisons
de retraite
donc les gens fragiles et leurs
soignants sont vaccinés pour l'instant
ensuite bas
on attend mars avril avoir un peu plus
de 2,25
concernant la stratégie et on va voir un
peu on n'a pas pu la leçon la france sur
quand même des gens qui ont des effets
secondaires qui doivent s'absenter de
trois jours une magnifique est d'une
efficacité peut-être sur le variant sud
africain ça laisse poser des questions
comme de partout on entend bas peut-être
attendre un peu plus la faille 0 le
moderne à là c'est un peu la question
mais sinon la campagne de vaccination se
poursuit et ça se passe bien merci
beaucoup xavier fallières d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin depuis
les pays bas je le rappelle vous êtes
médecin anesthésiste à l'hôpital de dors
très chaud